today we've got a lot of snow in England
well for England it's a lot of snow and
snow which is solid water frozen water
is really very interesting from a
chemical point of view one of the
problems about snow and ice and what's
affecting us here in England at the
moment is that when the snow falls on
the ground you want to clear it away
quickly so that people can drive around
and carry out normal life and it would
be enormous ly difficult to freeze the
to unfreeze the water with flamethrowers
or something like that because as soon
as you start heating it would called
down again and freeze salt sodium
chloride consists of ions na+ and cl-
and when they dissolve in water the
solution of sodium chloride has a lower
freezing point considerably lower
several degrees lower than pure water so
for by putting salt on the road you then
lower the melting point and so the ice
melts and cannot freeze again it's even
better if you use calcium chloride
because calcium chloride has twice as
many chloride ions for the calcium as
sodium chloride does and is even more
effective so in really cold countries
like Russia they often use calcium
chloride because you need less kilos of
calcium chloride to get the same effect
than you would with sodium chloride
[Applause]
let's begin with water water is h2o and
it has two hydrogen atoms and an oxygen
atom and you can say it's shaped like a
letter V now in ice and snow we get the
same arrangement of water molecules
though a light snowflake looks quite
different from a solid lump of ice that
might be in your glass of orange juice
and in both cases what happens is that
the two hydrogen atoms on the water bond
to the oxygen of other water molecules
and at the same time this oxygen atom
gets to bonds from two other water
molecules so in the atmosphere so ice
and snow have the same arrangement of
molecules inside but what they look on
outside is different and the reason is
because snow is formed by water vapor in
the clouds freezing to form crystals
without forming liquid at all and so
they produce these very nice hexagonal
shapes and this one I like it squeaks
and the precise shape is different from
every crystal that's formed many of them
are misshapen but every so often you get
one that is a perfect hexagon you can
see this boat over here
the book which was published so many
years ago at the beginning of the last
century is absolutely full of structures
of different snow crystals and every
snow crystal has a different structure
most of them looked as squashed and not
very nice but when you get a nice
hexagonal one it's an absolutely perfect
hexagon and in ice what happens the ice
that you make in your fridge or freezer
what happens is you take liquid water
which you just remove the heat with the
fridge and it begins to form a solid so
the difference is that snow freezes from
the atmosphere vapor of the water in the
atmosphere is going straight to the
solid snow we're not seeing all those
crystals now I can't say the crystals
well there are two reasons one is that
these are rather small but also because
you really have to see the crystals
properly you have to catch one as it's
coming down and even so most of them
don't look right I once saw one when I
was having a picnic on a hillside in the
north of England and it just landed on
my sleeve
and it was big enough so I could see the
hexagonal structure straightaway but
often the snow crystals are too small or
in England they tend to be rather wet so
they begin to melt and so this is rather
a musty mess compared to the nice dry
snow crystals that you might get
otherwise you can see I don't have a hat
and it's about to snow but like a real
chemist I've got my own solution to the
problem I've got nice umbrella which has
the periodic table on it and so I'll be
alright when the snow starts because I
can use my umbrella
you